- In Vegas people always
seem to say "Area 51,
don't say that".
- Benihana's.
- What? Benihana's, is Benihana
that kind of grill place
where they chop it and throw
it up in the air, right?
- Yeah, where everybody
thinks they can wear
Gucci shoes inside.
- Where everybody thinks they
can wear Gucci shoes inside?
Is that their slogan?
(laughter)
Benihana's, where everyone
thinks they can wear Gucci
shoes inside.
(laughter)
Anyone from Benihana's marketing in?
I've found you a new campaign.
Okay. I mean I'll take that
suggestion, I'm going to
give you the extra final
rule, which is if I've had
the suggestion before, I'll
be honest with you, I'll say
I've had that, I don't
do the same ones twice.
The best thing ever was
"ninth century crop rotation."
(laughter)
Someone said that once, that was good.
In the last show, some
guy down front was like,
"A Clockwork Orange", which
was a great suggestion,
he had neither seen the
film nor read the book,
so he was just fronting.
But, you know, maybe you
haven't been to Benihana's,
I don't know.
So, Benihana's where
people think they can wear
Gucci shoes inside is
the first suggestion.
That's come from over here,
so we'll kind of move here.
What do you want to
rap about, people here.
- Colonialism.
- Colonialism, now feels a
slightly obvious suggestion,
but obviously...
(laughter)
Let's pick an aspect of
colonialism that we can really kind
of drill down into.
- Powdered wigs.
- Powdered wigs! That was
a lovely whisper, yeah!
I heard that.
Colonialism, but really powdered wigs.
(laughter)
I think its, you know,
the main negative outcome
of colonialism was awful headwear.
Okay, Benihana's where
people wear Gucci shoes,
powdered wigs in colonial
times and colonialism,
this section here, what
do you want to rap about.
- Crop circles.
- That fits in with Benihana's.
- What? Crop circles
fits in with Benihana?
What? I've never been to
Benihana, but I've no idea.
Crop circles, yeah fine.
Guys over here.
- Stranger Things.
- Stranger Things, cool yeah.
What's the kind of acceptable
amount of plot to reveal?
Okay, we'll only include up to
season, the end of season two
maybe, I think season four
is coming out pretty soon.
I feel like you should've had
time to do up to season two.
Also, it's the only
season I've seen up to.
So there we go.
So Benihana's where people
think they can wear Gucci shoes,
crop circles, powdered wigs in
colonialism, Stranger Things.
And let's get one final one.
(audience shouting)
One second, I'm going to
come to you in a moment,
sexy bald black man.
(laughter)
I'm just gonna, just check
what this one, which definitely
is not as good as the
phrase sexy bald black man,
(laughter)
I'm just give him an opportunity
'cause he did say it first.
What was it?
- Waffle House.
- Waffle House, I'm sorry, no.
Okay so we have Benihana, where
people think they can wear
Gucci shoes inside,
colonialism and powdered wigs,
Stranger Things, crop circles
and sexy bald black men,
which, I mean the lights
are down low but I assume
you're not a skinny white guy.
(laughter)
This then, lovely people of
the Comedy Cellar, to kind of
close out the night-
- Mary Poppins!
- Shut the fuck up. To bring the show...
(laughter)
That's not even a suggestion, that's
just a heckle. Just...
"English motherfucker".
(laughter)
This is gonna be a freestyle
rap, that is a rap made
up on the spot base entirely
on those suggestions.
It's not written down, it's not rehearsed,
it's not prepared, none of
this will ever be seen again,
and don't worry it won't
be anywhere near as bad
as you're expecting it to be.
If we can drop that beat friend,
let's have some fun with this.
(rap beat starts)
Yeah, I'm excited, I'm excited.
No, it's gonna be good!
It's gonna be good.
We'll start with you.
(laughter)
♪ Date night, what might I do,
I open it all on my closet ♪
♪ Look the Gucci shoes, I got
the big G, wear it down there ♪
♪ And I hope to rock up to
Benihana and show my loafers ♪
♪ I don't take 'em off
the door I'm not a man ♪
♪ Livin' in the whole
cities inside Japan ♪
♪ That's what they do there,
I like to be the best ♪
♪ I'm in Benihana, a sharp knife chef ♪
♪ You can see me, choppin'
up the meat, I got thrills ♪
♪ When I flip it on the
blade like a pancake grill ♪
♪ Choppin' all the veggies
and all the cilantro ♪
♪ And then I serve it
up wow, it's just so ♪
♪ So precise I chop an
egg with the cleaver ♪
♪ It's kind of take a knife
or bowl, much easier ♪
♪ But not as flashy as
crackin' it in the air ♪
♪ If you travel 1800's take care ♪
♪ If you're not British and
white they will look at you ♪
♪ And say "why do you not
have a nice buckled shoe" ♪
♪ You need to buck up your ideas kid ♪
♪ You've got shit, here
take a powdered wig, yes ♪
♪ Off we go, we're into there,
we ride the nice big boat ♪
♪ To India, we're going to
plunder all of the spices ♪
♪ Put your wig on straight,
yeah that's my advice ♪
♪ Is just ignore all of the
poor, the people that we murder ♪
♪ As long as you've got a
nice little curl there ♪
♪ Make sure the powder
is fresh and you've got ♪
♪ A gold doubloon button on your chest ♪
♪ Basically that's all we
need to discuss about that ♪
♪ I tried to lay it down like
Mel Gibson in a top hat ♪
♪ You've seen Signs, the Shyamalan movie ♪
♪ They put the crops down,
laid it circular smoothy ♪
♪ Aliens from space, down they go ♪
♪ They make a geometric shape in a UFO ♪
♪ But technically that
shit is a load of wank ♪
♪ It's a conspiracy, it's
done by a rope and a plank ♪
♪ You just ♪
(laughter)
♪ Pull it 'round, stand in the scheves ♪
♪ Make sure you don't tread
it down with your feet ♪
♪ It's so damn amazing
when the crops flatten ♪
♪ Let me tell you what
Stranger Things have happened ♪
♪ Than a retro show,
rippin' off John Carpenter ♪
♪ Going on Netflix, now
it's on to season four ♪
♪ How many more maybe seven,
like the main character ♪
♪ That would be Eleven,
yeah I did numbers out ♪
♪ I really go to the yard, ride a bike ♪
♪ With the actor Finn Wolfhard
and all the other guys ♪
♪ The small black dude,
and if he was older ♪
♪ And tried to improve,
his weight lifting ♪
♪ And lost his hair he
would be like this guy ♪
♪ Sittin' in his chair, he was just in ♪
♪ Bein' friend with
Dustin, so damn ripped ♪
♪ That his shirt is bustin' ♪
♪ He is so sexy he wouldn't be allowed ♪
♪ To eat any waffles
if he went to a house ♪
(laughter)
♪ He will be there, yeah sayin' coughin ♪
♪ I'm fuckin' ya'll up like
my name's Mary Poppins ♪
(crowd cheers)
♪ Makes no sense, sexy black man thanks ♪
♪ All of the family
working for Mr. Banks ♪
♪ Yeah that's how we do it,
it's fun to nice and play ♪
♪ That's the end of the
freestyle rap for ya'll today. ♪
(crowd cheers)